les particuliers ont trouvé porte close
tout l'après midi après l'agression qui
s'est déroulée ici aux galeries
lafayette de chalon sur saône ou un
vigile a été grièvement blessé à l'armé
blanche
il est 13h30 quand un individu tente de
dérober un flacon rayant des parfums le
vigile tente de mettre fin en vol à
l'étalagé
mais l'individu sort un couteau et donne
deux coups au vigile un à la gorge
l'autre sur l'avant bras
c'est un gendarme en civil présents dans
le magasin qui va mettre fin à
l'agression avec son arme de service
il oblige l'agresseur à lâcher son
couteau le vigile a été quant à lui
transporté à l'hôpital de chalon sur
saône mais ses jours ne sont plus en
danger
il est ressorti en toute fin d'après
midi le personnel du magasin est
évidemment sous le choc nous avons
rencontré un peu plus tôt son directeur
visiblement très ému il a souhaité
donner congé à l'ensemble de ses
salariés et fermer le magasin pour le
reste de la journée
la police scientifique a quant à elle
recueilli les premiers éléments de
l'enquète les bandes de
vidéosurveillance vont être examinés
ultérieurement pour tenter d'établir la
chronologie des faits l'agresseur est
quant à lui toujours en garde à vue